playstation has finally announced
spartacus aka the changes it's gonna be
making to ps plus making it
playstation's tiered competitor to xbox
game pass to talk about it i've pulled
together our console crew xbox expert
jordan remain
yo
and playstation pro hussein
absolutely
rigid to talk about these changes less
oh my god
i don't actually know if he's used that
one before
i hoped some time away from this show
would mean he dropped that but i guess
frothing
there's been a lot of chat about whether
or not playstation plus and all of its
tiers which we will talk about are a
worthy competitor to game pass or even
whether you should call them competitors
at all uh so let's get into it
transition
so i'm gonna quickly run us through the
new tears listen lucy
the only tears i'm interested in is the
mimic tears i thought you were going to
say the only ones you're interested in
are gamer tears
i'm interested in those as well but
specifically eldon rings mimickers right
now
so playstation plus now has three tiers
you got playstation plus essential which
is essentially the same as ps plus is
now so two monthly downloadable games
discounts cloud storage multiplayer and
the price remains the same uh 59.99
per year then you've got playstation
plus extra
which not unlike a patreon tier means
you get all the benefits from the
previous tier plus 400 ps4 and ps5 games
uh from first party and third party
which are downloadable so no streaming
here uh and that is 99.99 per year this
one actually sets it on par with the
same price as game pass ultimate which
is 14.99 a month um although game pass
ultimate can't buy in a year's bundle
which really annoys me but i will take
my gripes to big phil later
then you've got the third tier
playstation plus premium
god help me if i've been popping on the
mic i'm sorry if i have uh all the
benefits from the previous two tiers
including 340 extra games including ps3
games uh as well as ps1 ps2 and psp
games
so the ps3 games you can stream and the
others you can download or stream
depending on what's being on offer um
and as well if you live in a market
where you can't access the games like
there isn't any cloud streaming there
you will be able to
uh download a selection of games that
have been made available
lucy i did not realize until you just
said all of that out loud that the math
on this just like
doesn't add up and like if you buy this
on a monthly basis you are wasting so
much money like they definitely want you
to buy like the year subscribers and yet
xbox does not want you to buy a yearly
which is really annoying i'm quickly
going to finish this tier uh you've got
game uh trials time limited game trials
so we've actually seen playstation trial
out their trials previously um although
if i recall correctly they did have an
unfortunate thing where your download
time counted towards the time in your
trial and so you know sucks to be you if
you don't have good enough internet for
that this final playstation press
playstation plus premium is 119
per year or 17.99 a month playstation
now is no longer standalone service uh
and it won't be from uh june where
there's gonna be a phased regional
release
so
off the bat what do we make of this
the tears the game of tears
so i think the
it's important to think about why
they're doing this and i think there's
for me um my understanding of it is it's
like a dual purpose they need to
consolidate and they also need to kind
of have some sort of
um kind of uh
offering that is akin to a game pass or
akin to a netflix or akin to a amazon
prime there's been a lot of discussion
about oh this is is this a a game pass
competitor and i think that
we'll come to that discussion in a bit
but i think it's just saying is this a
game pass competitor is very a narrow
view of it is it a you should be asking
yourself like is this a competitor for
any subscription service and the reason
i say that is because ultimately people
have money money is finite for most
people and they need to make purchasing
decisions
based on the money they have so when you
are when you have fifty dollars a a
month a hundred dollars a year whatever
it may be and you're trying to figure
out what do i spend this on people
aren't specifically just thinking about
should i buy game pass or should i buy
playstation plus they're also thinking
about
should i buy amazon prime should i re-up
crunchyroll should i re-up netflix
should i i don't know get a gym
membership like the same pool of money
is being spent on all this thing and and
the same goes specifically
for game pass and i know there's a lot
of discussion about people saying this
is not stop you know
creating comparisons between um game
pass and and and playstation
fundamentally um or like thinking of how
they're positioned you're right the in
terms of format and offerings they're
not designed to compete fundamentally
however though because of that what we
just discussed where it's the same pool
of money being taken being used to spend
on services they are a competition
whether you like it or not like if i've
got a certain amount of money and i need
to make a purchasing decision and i
don't have the disposable income to buy
everything i need to pick they are in
competition and that's the fact of the
matter if you care about it or not
i think that it's an interesting move
from playstation in that they've
clearly created their own avenue where
it's not game pass but it's still a
service that people can pay money for
and feel like they have a big library of
stuff behold
our stuff somebody says for a for a fee
um
i think what's different about it is is
obvious like there's not as much of a
focus on
making it the place where you come the
moment a brand new game is out and
instead it's more of like a
huh i feel like i've got i want to play
something different what can i see let
me see what i've got going on here um it
feels more like going to netflix when
you're bored and and you want to just
find something to
waste the or kill some hours as opposed
to a new season of that show that you've
been eagerly anticipating is finally out
and i feel like that's a good place for
sony to be
i will say i don't think it's the most
exciting prospect i don't think it's i
mean
i'm representing sony to a degree but i
i play on everything and i have no
allegiances to any specific corporation
and no nor will i defend them on the
internet for no reason whatsoever
i think this is a very boring roll out i
think it's got it's got zero fanfare and
like they could not have made it any
less interesting if they tried
um like
they have done more with less in the
past to great success
let's not forget the infamous how do you
play a pre-owned game or how do you lend
a game from like it was literally shu
and who was it adam
just exchanging a disc
and that was like massive for them like
this could have been a moment where they
had they put a little bit of check some
graphics on it you know you know put a
nice swish little uh like a playstation
transition and say 300 games for this
much instead what they've done is
they've presented a list
confusing
not a lot not enough details on big
things that like there's no games i
mentioned in a meaningful way there's
like you know miles morales or whatever
yeah but those are only the ones where
it's like
uh because because also one thing they
didn't really mention and it was
confirmed uh later on but it was like
the ps plus collection which is a part
of ps plus if you have it and you're
playing on ps5 you get a bunch of ps4
games like you'll still have access to
that and you'll have games like god of
war which is mem which is part of the
ps4 collection but you'll also have
death trending spider-man
more combat 11 and maternal but it's
like
okay there's five six games that we
fully anticipate but what else are you
throwing at you can't just throw numbers
like 400 games plus an additional 350
like yeah i mean i would kind of argue
that
they can though like to to go off your
point tam of like competing with gamepad
stuff like that like game pass is xbox's
thing like if you take a game pass away
from xbox i think the series x and
series s are not nearly as popular
consoles as they are now
playstation like even without these
weird confusing boring subscription
models people are still going to buy
forbidden west they're still gonna buy
god of war ragnarok like
in this moment playstation does not have
to necessarily be exciting about their
subscription service it might come back
to bite them in the ass
later down the line once xbox's first
party studios might start pumping out
much better games fingers crossed but
as of right now in
2022 like
playstations fine like
no one is looking at playstation and
thinking like man i really wish they had
a subscription service so i could
actually have something to play on my
playstation 5 or playstation 4 pro it's
like no like this is
extra honestly added on to what the
they've already given us yeah i think
for us like it
as people who are engaged on a
day-to-day basis it's a little more
disappointing because we expected more
of it as a service it's perfectly
functional for the most part i think
everyone who is subscribed to
playstation plus will probably just roll
into the next uh month or whatever it
may be because the the baseline doesn't
change for them the price doesn't change
for that yeah they're fine and then if
they're lucky you'll get a bunch of
people who are like oh i'm gonna upgrade
and then
you know get access to these
mysterious 400 games that are gonna
appear one day so weird that there's
three tiers like i know xbox you could
argue has three tiers and that they have
games with gold game pass and then game
pass ultimate but like for playstation
to be like here's tier one and tier two
and tier three i'm like why wasn't there
just essential which is like just the
service that's still here and it's like
or you could pay extra and just get this
updated one i it must be some marketing
thing that i guess
when you present three options people
will go for the middle option or
something like that um like there's some
probably marketing psychology behind it
but at the end of the day like it's like
we said uh like we were talking about
earlier like they had two confusing kind
of branches of their online offerings
between playstation plus and playstation
now one being the the kind of um
streaming side of it and they wanted to
consolidate it to make it simpler so
they did that and in consolidating it
they've created three confusing tiers
now which is this doesn't make a lot of
sense to the average joe schmo and like
this the differences between you know
the the middle tier and the top tier are
like not immediately apparent to most
people who aren't us who are paying
attention to this stuff if you know what
i mean um and like it's just
it's not elegant in any way shape or
form and
a week from now no one's gonna care
but like
as from for us right now as it goes like
as as an announcement of something
that's a major change in playstation
services
it wasn't the most elegant way to do it
and it's kind of a surprise for sony
because sony are a little more
they they think about this stuff a
little more they they have like a
premium
kind of polish to almost everything they
do this feels like they just open the
door shouted into a room and then closed
the door and left and it's like ah
okay i guess we'll try and transcribe
what
this playstation person just shouted at
us and figure it out
i'd say i almost wonder if it'll evolve
in any capacity once
because they have bungie like they're
clearly wanting to go for the
more service
type games even though they've said for
the longest time it's like nah we're the
single player one and done kind of uh
console but
even so if you're going to tie anything
like this a subscription service to any
first party
service games wouldn't you
wait until both of those things were
ready to go and
again this might just be one of those
things that
playstations like look people have been
asking us to create something that
resembles game pass in some capacity for
years now and we just have to say
something even if we don't yeah
the announcement almost kind of sounds
like they just really did not want to
make this announcement but they just
felt like we have to say something
anything yeah that's that's what i was
going to add sorry lucy if you want to
say anything i realize i'm just yeah no
i mean i was gonna say that like also
it's very different approaches we kind
of touched upon this but it's like
xbox has game pass because you know they
started it in 2017 and at the time
they weren't necessarily
you know they were still in the
acquisition phase
and they didn't really have that many
first-party studios that were pumping
out these big big releases whereas sony
had been spending a little more time
refining that output and you know jim
ryan's comments where he's like
you know we're not gonna put those big
games on this service day one um because
what's he said he said
we feel if we were to do that with the
games we make it playstation studios
that virtuous cycle would be broken the
level of investment that we need to make
in our studio virtuous cycle
that would not be possible and we think
the knock-on effect of the quality of
the games that we make would not be
something that we feel gamers want um
one of it so the virtual cycle is where
the investment delivers success which
enables yet more investment which
delivers yet more success we like that
cycle we think our gamers like that
cycle our gamers these are my machines
what a fancy way of saying our games are
actually good we do not need oh what
what they're saying is that yeah our
gamers are like
our games are popping off so we don't
need that [ __ ] which i like to say is
our gamers like to pay yeah exactly
and like which is 100
and like 100
in their right to do so and i respect it
so much that is sony going like no one's
making games uh the kind of way that we
are we're basically making marvel movies
uh
effectively and we'll put it out how we
want and people will come we build it
and people will come and it's like yeah
playstation field of dreams yeah exactly
um and like that makes perfect sense and
keeping that in mind it kind of puts
context on why the the updates to the
playstation look the way the playstation
plus look the way they are they do and
why they have that policy where it's not
like we're not introducing brand new
games like they don't need to because
people pay pay the money as jim ryan
said to to play the next when god of war
ragnarok comes out people thousands and
thousands and thousands of people will
very happily spend as much money as they
need to to buy their game and they will
have no issues with it they won't be
online being like why isn't this coming
out and if they are sun they're going to
be like
can't hear you over all of the
cha-chings happening over here in this
room right now
um let's let's kind of bring this to a
bit of a close what is i think for me
the most disappointing like let's end on
it on a good and a bad
honestly i i don't mind the tears so
much because i recognize that like that
third tier is not for me i typically
don't stream
games um that way it's not i never
really dabbled with playstation now um
so if you know that is the way that you
prefer to play games the fact that you
have that tier and you have access to
that library i guess it's good in a way
for game preservation however the fact
that some of them are downloaded
oh downloadable and some of them aren't
is still a bit iffy like why not make
them all downloadable um not everyone
has the privilege of having a steady
internet connection
as anyone who's ever been on a video
call with me can uh suffice but i think
honestly like the thing that i'm
honestly most disappointed about is the
trials being locked behind that third
tier um
[Music]
because
i don't know if you would like to check
whether you want to pay money for this
game you will need to pay money to get
the taster yes yeah some
megalomaniac like villain [ __ ] happening
in there
and it's like so like
like that's not how you get someone
addicted to cocaine like no you're going
to give them
exactly the first thing you charge for
the second taste yeah it's almost like
jim ryan has never gone out onto the
streets and bought drugs
get a grip you know big phil has
disappointing i'll say that
wow
that was a joke for entertainment
purposes i'm not insinuating that big
phil has been buying
or that no
jordan where are you i'm trying to
desperately steer this ship back
i i'm kind of in just the same boat as
you lucy where i'm just kind of looking
at this and i'm confused at some of it
and at the same time i'm just like you
know
i'll probably just pay for the first
tier and just never think about it again
for the rest of my life unless sony
announces that they're changing it in
some capacity and
yeah that's
it's not exciting but again like until
xbox actually starts creating first
party studio games that are like on par
with what sony is doing i don't think
sony needs to be all that exciting with
its subscription services like look xbox
can have
game pass and we'll just dominate making
games that are just good on their own
which is not to say that xbox has
[ __ ] games across the board there are
some good ones but
a lot of the games i've enjoyed on game
pass have not been the first party once
they've been the third party once and
i'm sorry if the day i'm like i know we
love we love game pass we'll you know
we'll have it we'll use it i will have
ps plus
i'm intrigued to see what we all do with
this one but the day that we get excited
about a new subscription model is the
day that i know that we've lost it this
time
we consume too much late state
capitalism has won oh yeah
tam your final thoughts yeah i mean like
despite the rollout i am actually
excited about this service um i am not
too fussed about them not having like
major first-party games for the reasons
that we also discussed um
i i'm the thing that i'm most intrigued
about is the the backlog of games like
ps1 ps2 psp games that are available in
the premium and the uh extra um uh
tiers so i think inevitably when it
comes out i'll probably go to the um
year playstation plus expert here and
see
what's in there or i might just splash
out and get the full one because
it will all depend on what those games
are because if it's like
every fifa every ever released i'm okay
thank you very much i want sony to
distinguish this service by like finding
the gems finding the stuff that people
care about and doing the work to put
that out there like don't just do this
stuff that you know people are or
published are desperate to shovel onto
your service and curate it instead don't
roll up with hey we've got all the need
for speeds
get me a god hand get me a beautiful joe
like go out there and do the things that
i'll call me like whatever it may be
that you know people love don't just
allow anyone to like shovel their [ __ ]
onto onto your service just because you
they want to make some money um so
that's my hope and i am excited about
that the the downside is like i said for
me just like i wish there was a little
more like
fanfare around this
because i want to be more excited than i
actually am and i think if they were
like psp
here is this game we've put metal gear
acid
well there's nothing from the vito
i know vita is rita is live and well
still do you really want fanfare tam or
do you just want the announcement
sometimes like
we get spam
so often sometimes you just want the
problem is we have neither here we've
got no fanfare and we don't have the
details we need it's one or the other if
you're not going to have fanfare give me
a list of the 300 games if you are not
going to have the 300 games give me some
fanfare they didn't either and it was
like all right cool i'll just i expected
nothing and i was still let down yeah
exactly all right and i'm going to call
it there thank you tam and jordan if
you're watching along at home thank you
for watching and let us know what you
make of the new changes to ps plus in
the comments below catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you